all right um so a lot of you are trying
the drills now and you have to be very
careful because they're very subtle
drills even even as we work here it's a
constant refinement of being able to do
the drill right um otherwise it won't
produce the results you want we already
know through many podcasts and many
writings that the eego tripartite mind
is prone to the external Force engines
is prone to contestation
and it is also prone to cipation of the
drills that are to cultivate its
deconstruction so you'll do these drills
and you're really just doing external
Force engines bracing angles and
contestation okay um the pointers I've
given recently is just get in the
ballpark but as you're in the ballpark
continuously work on releasing muscle
tension and no arm movement no external
movement okay that if you keep using
those pointers and you take them
seriously um it it will be very hard for
the ego triart mind to assur the drill
and to block you from its deconstruction
okay so we're going to show how it's
also very beneficial to have a teacher
because that mind is so deceptive um
that premodern cultures identified it
with a trickster deity or a demonic
element
uh and there's a lot of Truth to that um
your teacher is someone who will um
exercise that demonic aspect out and
keep you from assuring the training and
blocking your access to the god M uh and
I'll show you how we do that okay so
it's very important that you still come
here um or you still share your videos
and not just try these things on your
own because chances are you're you're
doing wrong you're doing them in the
antithetical way okay so here we
go and again remember that he's not
casually pushing he's he's pushing okay
if he ever felt like he's not pushing
hard enough he he'll tell him push
harder okay and if he needs to he can
get two hands on there you really grind
in there to to experience what's going
on okay um so he's not just holding I
know I know it looks like that right I
know I know it looks like I'm holding
but I'm not there there's a lot of force
in there uh it just doesn't look like it
so I'm not I'm not standing
here and not pushing if you if you can't
ground you're going to have to need
you're going to have to get that bracing
angle okay okay so you're
driving and you're already getting
floated right okay so he's doing that
that's the first thing you have to
push he's going to
go okay and come
back and and what you do now is feel
what is happening
okay so we're already coming up do you
feel that
okay now start to notice where you first
sense that the beginning of that motion
okay it already happened no no it didn't
happen it already it's happening again
where you feeling in here
no it feels like everything gets stiff
and I just become a try put your
awareness in your uh in your lower
calves somewhere around here right and
feel when they start to want to keep
position
Flex hurt whatever
okay when they change stand normal stand
stand normal give your hand out out feel
what that feels like we that's neutral
okay we'll call that neutral although
it's not my friend but I want you to
feel how that area that I touch changes
before anything else happens in your
butt yeah do you see okay and so what
that does is you're like on two
sticks and it pull volts you over those
two
sticks no no different
then
this feel it and you'll see your energy
that's exactly what your energy does you
see okay so we come
back and now my eye when he goes when he
stands I already see he's pull
Bing he already carries a Laten tension
in the lower legs okay that's probably
related to martial arts iido do you know
what I mean you automatically go into
that
flection um so he's got to bring some
awareness
there release and let's and here I'll
guide the UK keep it at a at a pressure
before P pull bolts okay right but to
that
pressure no more right and now I'll task
him with
releasing that tissue
don't change your outer shape though
okay it's not an external thing where
you try to release and relax it's an
internal thing so no
movement don't change your eyes don't
change your hands nothing you
release don't change the
pressure release watch the breathing
don't don't move outside right just
release
that keep going there but we we already
lost pressure he's got this Angle now as
this shoulders coming up okay so we'll
stop and we'll do the other
side and what you can do as a
practitioner is stop stop starting in
your Martial Art Samurai okay more
releasing and then we're going to take
it you what you'll feel is the pole the
pull bow so when you start to feel that
which you should at your skill that's
where you hold it and that's where he
works on the releasing
don't move Outside
Inside okay all right so as as the
teacher observing here I can see
um a conscious breathing
and if you pay
attention go
ahead get to that same
spot this is what happened last time but
uh take a full deep
breath you see okay so what I what I
mean by that is um Chris if you don't
mind I know this is weird but come
around behind me you can just put your
hand there don't don't push into me
you're trying to feel what happens okay
so when Sean breathes it causes a
flexion okay but as I breathe my body's
breathing there's no flexion in my in my
body you you feel that abdomen expand so
you still
have a lot of latent unconscious
flection it's going to be very very hard
to to move past that uh and so you can't
really do the drill we got to do this
other drill which is a variation which
is you're going to take him to that
breaking point and he's going to
basically do standing corpse POS you see
and he learns to release that but you
have to be careful because when
you your preconceived notions of
breathing is actually not the breathing
that we want which is the body breathes
not I breathe okay because when you
breathe it generates the late flexion
and now we push over okay um so we can
do some things and and we've we've known
you guys have seen everybody's progress
as they've trained here and we've been
online for a long time and we were even
talking yesterday you have a lot of leg
flexion
still um you also have a lot
of um preconceived notions of what is
positional integrity and what is uh
projection right we we've talked about
that a lot uh so now the teacher comes
in and modifies like we modified that
last drill we can modify this and which
is why there's a seated set
uh not just a standing set lately we've
been doing the standing set because
Virginia has a bum kneat and that way we
can just stay standing but I myself
prefer the seated set
um it's more
[Music]
challenging and uh your adaptation is
only as good as you are challenged by
your environment so um for me the
standing stuff it just gets way too easy
I get very bored very quickly okay but
you might have to go to the seated set
to understand more without me there uh
what's happening and what's not
happening okay um first let me give you
my philosophy this stuff takes forever
to learn so I try to uh expedite that
process as much as
possible
um and for that reason
I'll go ahead and increase the
stressor um but maybe to the point where
that's beyond your C capacity to adapt
and now that's not a cultivation field
anymore that becomes an application
field there's no growth from there okay
so um someone asked me one time like um
why do you why do you work from katate
why don't you work from on the Torso
since it has so much to do with it and
we do there are those videos where we
climb up the arm and I'll demonstrate
that right here um but the reason why is
because the ego triar type mind is so
oriented towards external that I want to
tackle that problem more fully by giving
you the the lust of pushing on something
so that's why I stick that hand out okay
um but here we're going to take that
hand away and so and we're going to take
the legs away and and understand this
positioning so first let me show you
what we're working with will you take
that camera from
Virginia and then Chris is going to push
and Virginia's going to come
out and this is a different uh issue so
Sean's issue the one I want to tackle
and have been tackling with him is the
lower leg tension which is very very
common and then here we have
another and we are going to walk
watch where you feel so it already
happened okay what what might your
teacher be talking about what was
it come on the my pushing back okay and
prior to that what
happened you got turned right then you
push so let's watch again hold your
position and now the source is what you
want okay not the obvious gross end
result he's going to Gally start pushing
increasing pressure it already happened
do you see that it already happened it
you already went that
way you don't feel it okay I don't feel
like it's my will I feel like it's a
dire no don't don't try to um it's not
about will it your task in the drill is
positional Integrity remember that so
when you get turned you lost positional
Integrity now the ego tripartite mind
goes back in positional Integrity but
now you pushed on him do you see do you
get that so we want to look at the
beginning of the position it already
happened it already happened it because
now you're trying not to do it and
you're coming in okay
the attention already got there so and
here's why here's why that's happening
so in the same way that uh Sean is
usurping a settling and a sinking of
mass through
relaxation with flexion and trying to
hold uh a vertical bracing angle in the
lower
leg you uh
have this weakness in how do I hold
myself for the rotation that comes from
the fact that we have one side of the
body forward versus the other so we
should be able to see this let's go to
the last
drill you okay and he's going to
drive
okay I don't care just par parall pillow
I'm sorry but I don't care the width of
them okay and now now we see both both
come forward in her you see the reason
we only saw one come forward put the
foot back is because only one shoulder
is being affected do you see that but
prior to you coming forward we saw the
compromisation of it going back so the
skill that is still missing is how do I
hold structural Integrity in light of
this rotational Force okay that's what
that's where we're going to go okay
let me let me use Sean so Virginia take
that all right so here we'll we can
start um without the legs okay he can
Flex his legs all he wants here it won't
do anything okay it's not going to do
anything so he's going to
push and he's got to drive
and I am very
relaxed I keep releasing
tension I let my body
[Music]
breathe I scan the entirety of my body
for that
tension and what do you feel like well I
didn't even you already move but what do
you what it feel
like it well you already tired right so
that's something you should say that's
how hard he's pushing okay he's he's not
just holding here he's not just here he
he's driving driving driving driving
okay the same thing this this is for
someone like Sean is on the flexion on
the lower legs maintain position don't
relax by doing movement okay I you just
can't see me relax on the inside but
it's on the inside that I start to
release
tension wherever I feel the urge to push
I let go of
that I don't seek any mechanical
advantage over him or anything
you can see I got a little push keep
going but I release
it you only get pushed because you Flex
so I release it
Again release it
again okay
and what I'm doing here is I get to
release tension and two I'm going to
work on
this positional Integrity of the Torso
do you get that because that's where a
lot that that's another place that is
very difficult um releasing tension in
lower legs is very difficult and
maintaining rotational integrity in the
Torso is also very difficult at first we
meaning we tend to do it through flexion
and
contestation okay so that's where we're
going so let's we're going to try this
drill for a little bit
okay okay so stay there and don't move
but you can see he has this
orientation here's your shoulder back do
you see that so we we came here and so
we're assuring it we're trying to get
skeletal alignment okay and that's why I
like to work with katate and not on the
Torso okay cuz this is a stronger
Catalyst for the ego tripartite mind
than the Torso is you you could fix your
torso all you want and then when I give
you your arm or I grab your arm or I do
things to your arm and you will go right
back to the contestation it's the same
thing in my opinion that you could you
could sit on that freaking
cushion you know you you could be a a a
male practitioner of Zen you sit on that
cushion uh all the all the time in your
little Hermitage I give you a
wife and now you don't know okay
it's the same it's the same thing the
environment is uh at a whole other level
um it's why as I said I'm not in the
monastery you have to take your practice
into the swamp the the Lotus is born in
the swamp it's not in a pristine
hydroponic environment okay so he'll go
we'll set him up he'll
go and not it's not external it's
internal
interal and what do you feel as you're
trying to do it don't
move uh I feel the tension in the
shoulder and I'm trying to get it here
so try to release that tension there you
go and again it'll rise up because
that's what the Mind does and you
release it Again release again there you
go and again where else do you feel
tension pay attention to the lower back
and the leg still release it again
good good
okay um so again the drill is not really
to make to keep positional it's not a
positional Integrity drill wh why would
it be um we're never going to contest
for space this is where I deviate
radically from from uh Adam Meisner
because he sticks with that cultivation
field I am never going to stay in place
the non-c contestation is going to
concentrically expand out from the
internal to the external and I will
never contest for space let alone just
be uh handle it inside that's not what
we do here um and so likewise the drill
is not about positional Integrity the
the stressor is positional integrity
but it is my
reaction to the
stressor that's compromising positional
Integrity in the face of the other
stressor the desire to maintain
positional Integrity those are all ego
tripartite mind aspects and I am
monitoring my reaction to those two
catalysts that stimulate ego tripartite
mind activity that's what I'm doing so I
release and I release and I release and
I release that is what I'm doing that's
the drill okay all right so we're going
to go
on and here's where someone will make
another very similar uration a mistake
in understanding the drill um we're
going to do the one where he climbs up
the arm so he he has to trade grips and
allowing me to move he'll climb up to
the Elbow okay and then from the elbow
he climbs up to the shoulder
and we're here like that
okay uh a lot of people will
think and at this level of that my dishy
are at that are here today um I'm this
is for future thought okay a lot of
people will think that this shoulder and
this is for you Virginia that you have
to learn the groove to set the shoulder
where it can
relax Chris was doing that
subconsciously when he tried to bring It
Forward like that you see cuz he felt it
going
out that is all an uration because that
is all
external and I can't I can't let's say
you wanted to fight I can't fight with
set shoulders that that doesn't work I
know you see a lot of iido people like
that but that doesn't work and here's
how you know it doesn't
work the premodern epistemology is most
clearly outline in theara's tetralemma
and so it's a it's B it's both A and B
it's neither a nor B so there's no way
it can be it's set it has to be I can
set it I can unset it I can both set it
and unset it and I can do something
that's neither set nor unset okay so my
my arm for example doesn't require a
certain anatomical alignment of skeletal
and muscular tissue my my arm is he's
going to push and keep pushing and my
arm can do whatever that I want it to do
can do whatever can even
do things is not supposed to do he
should be able to shove it there but he
can't
can okay just in terms of a fighting
capacity is that not better that you
don't have to fight like that the entire
time okay
so I kind of let beginners work with set
and then we start to work with unset as
we get going
okay but setting with tension that has
to be addressed from the very beginning
because that's not the drill Okay so
what we're going to do
is take
away this alignment and urge to push by
moving up the arm so the pointer here is
for your UK to kind of keep the same
pressure and you pay attention to what's
happening in the rest of your body
then the next one I want you to go from
shoulder to
chest tight in the
middle watch for you watch watch this
feel what you feel now
your hand was
amaz that's the release of the
tension there's the breathing without
the positional Integrity
change and again I I let it all go and
you're you're going to go flying okay
all
right here's the reverse
engineering if there wasn't tension and
skeletal alignment keeping my hand in
place the integrity was not sourced in
the wrist or in the shoulder the
positional Integrity it's sourced
somewhere
else it's sourced in this spinal
position do do you understand that so if
you're here
standing that's the whole point of this
one the source is in the spinal
Integrity all external distal Integrity
is sourced in spinal integrity that's
why you can do this drw that's why it
doesn't change it if you have to do this
then you don't have the spinal Integrity
okay if you get
rotated you don't have the spinal
Integrity because that spine rotated
spinal Integrity is
here that's why this stuff works spinal
Integrity is
here I would have to rotate my spine in
order to fall victim to that okay all
right so we're going to try this seated
drill and I recommend you try this drill
because you tend to have so much tension
and iido
trickery that you're hiding from
yourself that you don't have the spinal
Integrity okay all right so we're going
to play with this